we're gonna be looking at alcohol today
and in particular ethanol because
ethanol was the
alcohol that most of us are most interested in
It' Martin! How was the filming, Martin? It's only just begun.
This is a model for ethanol: two carbons,
5 hydrogens here, oxygen here,
and another hydrogen there. Most people are familiar with alcohol
because of alcoholic drinks.
One of my colleagues
at my old university did point that it looked
a bit like a dog shape
so although hair of the dog is an English
term referring to an alcoholic drink
you drink
in order to combat hungover it doesn't
come from the shape the molecule
beer wine all sorts of things like vodka
these all made by fermentation
of some natural material, maybe juice
from some sorts of fruits
like a grape or some sort of grain
wheat
barley and so on today what we gonna do
with all these different
alcoholic drinks is actually distil
them so the process of distillation
will actually purify these alcoholic
drinks it all mean that we can actually
get as as close to pure alcohol as we
can
alcohol has been terribly important in
human history
because in the days before people
discovered how to purify water
they used to drink wheat beer where the
alcohol
killed most of the bacteria and so they
could drink safely
in a Asia people used to boil water and
make tea
but this wasn't discovered in Europe and
and the West to many many years later
what we're going to do now is actually
distill the alcohol
out of a kind of beer so beer is going to
go into that large flask there
will connect up to this which is known
as the store head topic that will be of
the moment so alcove label
clicked around here go down this arm and
into this bit not here
without you got so cold running water
are creating a jacket above coolness
around the a glass tube inside it so the
alcove a power
will get condensed into liquid outflow
down
into the receiver into our a round
bottom flask
alcohol has now certainly
or ethanol you sell alcohol has become
enormously important as a possible means
absolving out transport problems you can
burn
ethanol in car engines you can mix it
with gasoline to produce and material
which will still operate in car engines
you can make the ethanol
from also two different grains from
wheat
from maize ??? cool points for a
living
(laughing intensifies)
It's ridiculous
surely abysmal job good
there you go can a beer in the flask
now gonna heat up the iceman toes are
heating up side
that were actually heat up the sides and
the bottom of this round bottom flask
so what's going to happen is that you
put alcohol and water inside
that vessel the water should stay in
there until
you know if we go up to 100 degrees C
any them when it boil but before we get
to 100
Alcohol will come off first around about
78°C
any organic compound that
contains
and oxygen hydrogen group is known as an
alcohol
people when they talk about ethanol
usually also called alcohol but
you can get ehmm.. so-called methyl alcohol
methanol which has CH3OH
and you can make these methanol
by distilling wood and is sometimes
known as wood alcohol
it's very poisonous causes
blindness
and quite frequently that methanol
is added to ethanol to stop people
drinking it so-called
methylated spirits but there are a whole
series of alcohols
propanol, butynol, pentanol and so on
and all of them a used in making
chemicals doing chemical reactions
but ethanol is by far the most common
and so alcohol when chemist is talking
is often the shorthand for ethanol but
the alcohol there
which is bubbling up forming alcohol vapour
into this area which is still hot
so
what will happen is there is vapour
once it hits
scope of glass
condenses on it and is trickling down
flows along the condenser
so what we're going right at the end
here into the receiver
and then into the round bottom flask is
the alcohol from beer
one of the problems when you distill
alcohol
from water is that you cannot get it
a 100 percent pure because ethanol
and water form a so-called azeotrope
what distills over is 97 or 98 percent
pure but you can't get rid of the last
two percent
water the only way you can remove it is
by adding a third material
quite often people add benzene to it
so the alcohol that we have in the lab
doesn't contain much water but it does
contain nasty things
which means that if you drink them you
could be seriously poison
for this kinda beer we've managed to get
about this much alcohol
and say no huge amount but that's what
we've managed achieved our
crude distillation apparatus here but
there you go
I drink some wine unfortunately but I don't
like beer
which is a real disadvantage in some
countries
where beer drinking it's a big tradition
so I'm fail and when I go to countries
like Germany or Belgium
I can't really appreciate their national
drinks
we're going to be putting some fortified wine now into our
round bottom flask and not be connected
to the distillation apparatus
alcohol is used in the lab quite
frequently
very often as the solvent for doing
chemical reactions
it can also be used just for
washing things because it will dissolve
quite a wide range of
organic compounds so if you wash your
flask in alcohol
then you can get nice clean glassware
it should come off about 78
there are bacteria that can
oxidize ethanol they turn ethanol
into ethanoic acid, citric acid
it's what makes vinegar
and so if you have a bottle of wine
it.. leave it open to the air or and leaks
into the bottle
it starts getting acid welcomes more
like vinegar
and when I was teenager again
I was quite an enthusiastic chemist
my father opened the bottle of wine
which was a bit acid so I had this
brilliant idea
I took a so-called ion exchange resin
that removes the acid
from anything and I pulled his wine
through the ion exchange resin
it was a fantastic success it stop being
acid
but its tasted absolutely foul
right and there we have it so there's wine
as the Alcohol from it, Cheers!